hi kate
how are you good how are you i'm good
i want to say congratulations on so many
things season four loved it
the sag award nomination for the whole
cast yeah well deserved
i thought so i i was hoping that some of
the actors would get
individual noms
kelly
you know
being being the main one that i just
think that she just has this impossible
job and she does it so unbelievably well
yes um and you looked amazing that suit
was
chef's kiss
thank you my girlfriend uh picked that
suit out for me at the like at the 11th
hour after resisting like fashion help i
was like i can do it on my own and she's
like you can
well collaboration was on point i loved
it um i have three words that i use to
describe season four and they are not
enough teeter
thank you that's so nice i was not
expecting that um
thank you
i mean i
i love playing that part
i i get to do so much more than what
ends up on camera because the scenes are
usually so sprawling
um so i get to inhabit her and and spend
time with her more than i think the
audience does but
yeah i mean
that would be great but if not
that would be great too
well we love her from this side of the
screen i'm not the only one
um
i want to ask is this something that
taylor is going to rectify in season
five are we gonna get more teeter
hey
hey can we get taylor to watch this
should should i write a strongly worded
letter to him myself
yeah can you write a strongly worded uh
letter
i don't know if i'm gonna get i don't
know if we're gonna get more teeter
we don't know anything usually until we
get the scripts like a week before
but um i do really trust him
i really do trust him so much in terms
of amount that he like exposes an
audience to with a character and whatnot
i think he's really smart um
about
i thought he was really smart about not
over saturating the audience with this
character because she is
a certain pitch
um
and i feel like i might have some some
longevity the longevity that i've had
and getting to go into the next season
for sure is because he didn't like ram
her down people's throats yeah because
you know
dick teeter is an acquired taste
we that we love
you have to start you you start in small
amounts and you're like i don't
i don't know
and then you're like it's
it's kind of like it hurts so good like
it eventually
you're addicted to this thing that
you're just like
well i wouldn't say that was my response
but i i love that so much and like i
can't i live for her babies i love i
live for them the the the the babies
yeah
yeah the no i mean it is by the way
i we had before i started shooting
like the first episode i got to spend a
little bit of time with denim richards
who plays
um colby and i was like listen um
gosh i'm used to this conversation
happening the other way around where the
male actor is having to at talk to the
female actress um about what they're
comfortable with and i really was like
we have to have really clear
communication because i am essentially
um sexually harassing you
for the entire
first season that we do together so
let's let's try to be clear about
boundaries
yes i actually love that you bring that
you're you're sending my interview right
off on a different tangent that i was
expecting but i love that you said that
because it is such a uh an interesting
gender bend her character especially
with her relationship with colby because
if we especially in this show if we'd
seen that the other way around
i think it would have come off very
harsh right it would have come off
really harsh and and it would have
caused in my opinion a slew of other
issues um
based on a myriad of factors that like i
mean we could do a whole half hour
segment right about race and gender and
presentation and all sorts of stuff um
so
this sort of flipping of
the script just on the gender front
is really is really interesting and
gender is actually like a very
interesting thing for me with teeter and
it's like
um
she
doesn't really exist in a gendered world
like you know this is never a scene
that's been shot but it's certainly one
that like i've thought about which is
like when they shower in the bunk house
she's not like getting out of the shower
and like putting a little towel on like
it's just like
we shower we're naked we get dressed
that's how it goes and for her
that's just normal
yeah and which is why i think we love
her so much right like that's right
she's sort of i always think of teeter
as sort of pre-civilization
in any way you know there's this like
great quote i think there's i'm gonna
misquote it in this book sapiens um
where it says like uh biology uh biology
allows and culture forbids and like
teeter's animal so there's really no
nose with her
i love it
now
we could i could spend the rest of my
time with you talking about how much i
love twitter because i i just love her
that much i want to talk about the
really emotional storyline that she went
through this season because i think um
i think it i think it's really important
like you said for the future of her
character that we know that this is
something that's very important to her
so what was it like for you to sort of
tap into the emotional side of teeter
you know after she gets sort of booted
from the bunkhouse for something that is
absolutely not her fault
yeah that's like such and and it ties
into what you were talking about before
because she gets lumped in with girls in
the bunkhouse it's like
what the hell no man i'm
i'm a ranch hand i do my job i work my
butt off um
i loved it because there is a is as fun
as it is to play teeter at that sort of
like guarded caustic
you know uh fun
self there is an underbelly of emotional
life that i get to experience that i
don't get to like live out on screen as
much
and um
one of the things that was really clear
to me even in season three
was
peter's deep deep need for family i
always had this strong feeling that she
lost her family that she was raised with
a bunch of older brothers and
went by her father she definitely feels
like a motherless child
and that she really lost her family you
know to a host of issues sort of that
affect
you know
ranch america
uh
and so that
the dutton ranch is really home for her
and
yeah that was always something
so for her like losing
losing her home there
where does she go
you know like i always thought about
like teacher's not 20.
you know she's been a mobile worker for
a while like she found her home
and like so it's devastating to think
about that going away
absolutely and i think that that um
i think that like that line that she
says where she has you know her whole
life in the back of her car
um really speaks to that to that moment
for sure yeah yeah yeah i was very i
that scene when i read it i was like
it messed me up
now quick final question
because of everything that's happened do
you think that in season five we're
gonna get our teeter-colby relationship
oh my gosh
i tend to it's i think it's an actor
thing not to think about those things
because
you don't know what's gonna come
i think if you get it i think if we get
it
it'll be in a really refreshing way that
doesn't feel like and now we're a thing
like
um
because she's got some like boundaries
and rules that she you know it's like
you said does she want to keep her
family or does she want
this sort of thing i find it's very
interesting that's really interesting
and bringing up the conflict inside of
that uh
i don't know
i don't know this is always weird and i
say this in interviews and then i regret
it which is like
i do wonder
how how teeter
has sex
like how weird is it
like how taboo is it like
i don't know i don't know if we're going
to see that
taylor will if taylor decides to do it
though
it'll be great
amazing i'm
i love that we ended on that yeah
this was amazing for me thank you so
much so much